just yesterday in Mexico thousands of
Mexicans marched to protest
President Trump and his policies well I
wanted to take things any more positive
direction so here's the plan as I've
said later this week I am flying to
Mexico City where I'm gonna do that
following I'm gonna rent a television
studio and shoot an episode of our show
with the help of an all Mexican staff
crew guests and studio audience were
calling it Conan Without Borders made in
Mexico
[Applause]
it's really cool we've already have two
amazing guests as I've said one of the
stars of rogue one a Star Wars story
diego luna is going to be joining me and
the former President of Mexico Vicente
Fox will be telling us his news on
various matters I'm sure it's gonna be
an amazing show I am concerned about one
thing okay I have heard that the Mexican
people are very excited that I'm coming
to their country but then I saw this
photo from yesterday's protest in Mexico
this is a real photo yeah
I'm really hoping that that is Trump
that they burned in effigy that looks it
could be Trump yeah but it looks
suspiciously like me I'm just saying
things could go either way down there
I'm coming with good intentions yeah I
hope that we are well everything oh good
thanks a lot easy fix it all all right
anyway I still think it's gonna be a
great show conan Without Borders made in
Mexico will air on Wednesday March 1st
at 10:00 p.m. right here on TBS
[Music]
[Applause]
you